let's talk about net neutrality we've
been doing a bunch about it I really
beyond the money in politics thing I
think this is the most important thing
going on right now so the FCC struck
down net neutrality it didn't look like
they were gonna do it but they did net
neutrality is the basic principle that
everyone deserves equal internet access
and that the Internet service providers
have to provide the highway should be
equal for everybody
now they flip that so that the companies
can throttle the internet so if you
don't think that's important to you
let's say you're someone who watches The
Young Turks there's a chance right if
you're watching this and you believe in
alternate media
well if Time Warner which owns CNN says
well you know we don't like those Young
Turks because they're not given the
appropriate message well then they can
actually start throttling the speeds
with which you get the Young Turks
videos get these videos so this is
hugely important and especially now in a
time when the mainstream media has
failed us miserably and Cable News is a
disaster and all that so what again
we'll start with the broad thing was the
internet broke and I didn't know it was
there was that really a problem here
that the FCC had to jump in and get
involved it was were you finding that
the internet was broke it was only
broken to the people who were suddenly
losing their power and money that's who
it was broken the rest of us were like
hey look we have more power and access
to our consumers and to our audience
directly now this is amazing this is
like you know the 60s all over again
is that a free love with other people
it's a lot of porn you know that the
front-runner but yeah it was not broken
I just love the way they're couching
this the FCC - they're like trying to
say but as consumers you're gonna be
happy because when you're streaming your
Netflix video there'll be no glitches
because will give Netflix and people
like that priority which you know I get
it at 2:00 a.m. when I'm watching the
bridge I want to you know have it
flowing correctly but yeah
this is all based on the fact that and
everyone will play fair don't worry
everyone's going to be fair about this
so you've given me the perfect segue so
we've got a quote from the FCC chairman
he said to be very direct the
establish that behavior harmful to
consumers or competition by limiting the
openness of the internet will not be
permitted
now that sounds nice and that sort of
sounds like were you were saying but it
doesn't there's no nothing there's no
teeth in that they're gonna they just
decided to change what was working and
then say well we promised to not screw
it up any further yeah but God forbid
you say [ __ ] you know [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
what is it well first we got to get to
the voter fraud because there are four
of them through [ __ ] history and so
make sure everyone has to have an ID so
they can't vote and I'm the same guy
that thinks this is another important
law to put it that's the same exact
mindset as that is an artificial problem
to take command back from people who are
getting power from those other stories
we were talking about earlier that
you're changing the way we make money
you came if you [ __ ] with us now we
got it we're gonna pull the law going
with a little bit of a conspiracy theory
here could this possibly be why CNN gave
us three months or whatever it is of
24-hour plain coverage because they want
to keep our eyes off the real problems
because they are owned by giant
corporate conglomerates that gain access
and gain the money that you're talking
about and we're the ones threatening
them of course you could see it that way
but really CNN once your eyes just to be
on them they don't care what you're
ignoring they just want their I mean
they had the best ratings and what five
years or something like that really says
a lot yeah so I know I'm not a I'm not
one two people sitting in a room and you
know making up decisions about this you
don't need a conspiracy theory the
system is already you know against us so
yes that's my personal view do we need
what you've been talking about a couple
times so far do we need this groundswell
of support starting at the bottom people
taking to Twitter Facebook you know the
99% all that - is that the only way we
have a chance to get this thing fixed
when have we not mm-hmm when has that
not been the case when has that not
worked yeah it always works same key
same lock every time like works every
time you took put it into it just you
gotta look for the key I'm too busy I
got other stuff I got to do
someone will do what someone will hit
the lock for me where's everyone at once
it's like one of those nuclear missile
things or two people got to put the key
in but it's an every one key turn every
once I do believe that innovation I mean
you know the internet and and everything
around it you know is is all about young
minds innovating with things that we
can't even begin to ponder and I I think
there's going to be some young turk
somewhere in the back of her room and
he'll be like I figured out the way to
open up a billion times this over here
this space and we'll all jump in there
and the corporation's would be like what
hey why isn't anyone watching our stuff
anymore and we're all over there I you
know who knows then they'll jump in and
control them and someone will do it
again and that's the way it is that's
the way innovation works that's the way
that's the way our democracy works
that's the way evolution works
I've been fox rabbit and Fox yeah Kelly
Carlin you gave me a little hope at the
end of this segment I did not know that
there was hope when you when it comes to
the FCC but apparently there